hi welcome The Trews news the only place
that you can trust for news I'm your
host Russell Brand X arrow and junkie
and former comedian
I guess current comedian really but news
news subscribers the only place you can
trust
rusty Rockets is at it again
the important thing is that we keep
mentioning Islamic state and I see why
is he mentioning that because they're
safe all they know is that one fella
they said was a jihadist sympathizer
okay he was a terrorist he tried to go
to Syria and he was at least inspired in
part by Isis it's not just conjecture
we know that okay but Russell wants to
defend some people here from unfair
generalizations and I can dig that the
god is a recent Muslim convert also has
mental health issues if you met a person
and like you haven't cup of tea with him
they go tell me about yourself Oh
I recently converted to Islam did yeah
yeah also I've got mental health issues
and then a minute later Eli so smashing
the plates up I'll go my you're mentally
ill stop smashing the place up wait did
he just make an unfair generalization
because I work with special needs people
and most of them are nonviolent entirely
peaceful happy people mental health is
not the constant here this is in the
Quran so stuff about smashing the plates
up you know I steal rights convenient
for their argument yes yes it is in the
Quran and that's the point the constant
here is not the Canadian government not
the American government not mental
health but the Quran and its holiest
Prophet Mohammed sexism be upon him it's
an attack on all of us is it is it
really all those institutions protecting
all of us I know that's what you're
saying but I mean where's the evidence
evidence I don't know how about we start
with the right to vote freedom of speech
women being protected from rape or
domestic abuse all rights not afforded
to them by the Islamic religion or legal
system for which you so often create a
false moral equivalency shoes many men
is if you won't if you might drive a car
where you order if you want don't be a
bloody Muslim load and do it because
then we will use that to marry voltage
right because it's a race thing it
couldn't have anything to do
with the fact that the vast majority of
global terrorism has carried out in the
name of Islam or that even a shocking
number of so-called moderates support
terrorist activity like suicide bombing
so to be fair Russell does call out some
of these people she's an extremist that
what was the extremists for you Russell
good for you mr. brand recognizing evil
ideologies where they stand like Islam
no wait never mind he was just talking
about Tracy burns from Fox Business
different than my own on things like
supply-side economics or the legitimate
purview of government so I'd have to
point to her as evil extremist rather
than those who believe a religion where
you can legally beat your woman and hang
your gays oh yeah based Emily to do with
is to do if Islam isn't it properly this
I mean it'll be good if it was it but
not being convenient Trimble in that
Oklahoma bomber Tim McVeigh blew out
that building it was a white blow so the
brown person who threw something and
then we can have our Wallace we did that
young man just say that the American
media ignored Timothy McVeigh because he
was white and they couldn't use it for a
war for oil googling Timothy McVeigh
literally yields hundreds of thousands
of results in the Oklahoma City bombing
was actually the most media covered act
of terror ever outside of 9/11 actually
had to wait back all the way to 1995 to
support my argument while simultaneously
wading through Islamic terrorist attacks
committed at an average of five per day
it's almost as difficult as entirely
using Fox News as my main source for
rebuttals while trying to paint it as
representative of mainstream media the
only one who finds it ironic that a
Hollywood celebrity who by the way is
known most for his Papa SH micromanage
manicured phony sexually ambiguous look
is now criticizing Society for its
devolvement into narcissistic shallow
covering of news his shtick is almost as
dissing genuine as his laugh laugh or
does he have Ebola that is some truths
true new true news don't get caught up
in celebrity speculation subscribe you
yes today is opposite day because I'm
clearly a
celebrity with nothing more than an
opinion they only sell rich it'll give
you cow